digamos que estamos tratando de calcular
cuánto es 2 dividido entre una décima
pausa el vídeo y trata de resolverlo muy
bien hay un par de maneras en que
podríamos abordar esto podríamos
intentar pasar todo en términos de
décimas ya que estamos dividiendo entre
una décima y en lugar de dos unidades
podemos reescribir dos como 20 décimas
divididas entre una décima de modo que
si tienes veinte de algo y quieres
dividirlo en grupos de uno de ese algo
cuántos grupos vas a tener bueno vas a
tener veinte grupos así que esto será
igual a 20 esto es interesante todos
dividido entre una décima es igual a 20
ahora qué pasa si tuviera que dividir no
sé voy a inventar algún número digamos
que tengo 7 dividido entre una décima
cuál va a ser el resultado bueno es la
misma idea siete unidades
es lo mismo que setenta décimas
y si lo divido entre una décima
bueno 70 de algo dividido en grupos de 1
de ese algo será 70 grupos iguales esto
va a ser igual a 70 de modo que 7
dividido entre una décima es igual a 70
todos dividido entre una décima es igual
a 20 podrías notar un patrón ahora hay
otras maneras de abordar esto podríamos
haber dicho algo así como 2 dividido
entre una décima es lo mismo que dos
sobre una décima y voy a escribir una
décima de esta manera y así cuando
dividimos entre una fracción es lo mismo
que multiplicar por el recíproco esto es
lo mismo que 2 por 10 y entonces ese
patrón es un poco más claro será igual a
20 cuando divides entre una décima es lo
mismo que multiplicar por 10 lo mismo
sucedió aquí cuando dividimos entre una
décima fue lo mismo que multiplicar 7
por 10 para llegar a 70 entonces qué
crees que va a pasar si dividimos entre
una centésima digamos que tengo 6 y
quiero dividirlo entre una centésima
pausa el vídeo y trata de resolverlo
bueno una forma de abordarlo es expresar
lo todo en términos de centésimas
de modo que 6 se puede reescribir ya que
cada entero es igual a 100 centésimas
seis enteros o seis unidades será igual
a seiscientos centésimas esto será igual
a seiscientos centésimas y luego eso se
dividirá en grupos iguales de una
centésima así que si tengo seiscientos
de algo y lo estoy dividiendo en grupos
iguales de uno de ese algo cuantos
grupos iguales voy a tener bueno voy a
tener 600 grupos iguales ahora otra
forma de abordar esto es con fracciones
podríamos haber dicho que esto es lo
mismo que 6 sobre una centésima lo que
podría expresar de esta manera que es
igual a 6 por el recíproco de una
centésima 6 por el recíproco de una
centésima que es 100 sobre 1 y podríamos
escribir esto como 100 lo que una vez
más nos da como resultado 600 así que
tal vez estás viendo un patrón de nuevo
cuando divides entre una centésima eso
equivale a multiplicar por 100
divides entre una décima eso equivale a
multiplicar por 10 lo voy a dejar aquí y
te invito a que pienses en eso